hello this is presto occur in a previous
video I showed you how you can do the
times table from six through ten on your
fingers in this video I'll explain why
this works the method begins by
numbering the fingers on your hands six
through ten to do seven times eight we
line up the finger four seven on the
left hand with the finger four eight on
the right hand we then count the number
of fingers including the fingers which
are touching that are below the fingers
which are touching there were five
fingers in this figure
these are the TENS units so this becomes
50 on the left hand there are three
fingers above the touching fingers and
on the right hand there are two fingers
above the fingers touching we multiply 3
& 2 to get 6 and that gets us our answer
of 56 but why does this method work I'll
try and explain the problem in another
way let's try and do 10 minus 3 times 10
minus 2 this is the same problem of 7
times 8 but we'll think about it as 10
minus 3 times 10 minus 2 on the left
hand we rotate three fingers from the
pinky and on the right hand we line up
two fingers from the pinky we then count
the number of fingers which are below
the fingers that are touching this is 10
minus 3 on the left hand and then we
subtract 2 for the fingers that are
above the touching fingers on the right
hand so what we're doing here is 10
times 10 minus 3 minus 2 which is 50 now
we count the number of fingers which are
above the touching fingers there's three
on the left and two on the right we then
multiply these to get 6 and that once
again gives us 56 so now you can see why
the process works in general we'll think
about it algebraically what we're really
doing is we're multiplying 10 minus a
ten minus B where a is the number of
fingers above the touching fingers or
from the pinkie and B is the same
quantity on the right hand the two
fingers were touching we label as ten
minus a and ten minus B now how many
fingers are below the touching fingers
while we subtract a fingers on the left
and B fingers on the right from ten in
total so this becomes ten times ten
minus a minus B we then multiply the a
and B fingers which are above to get a B
and this is why the reason works we're
essentially doing the foil method of ten
minus a times 10 minus B but using our
fingers in a concrete method so it's
totally valid technique and it's pretty
cool that it works I hope you liked this
video please subscribe to my channel you
can get my books there's a link in the
video description you can catch me on my
blog mind your decisions which you can
follow on Facebook Google+ and patreon
and you can also catch me a pressure
Locker on a bunch of social media sites